grant thanks for coming in buddy i know
you don't believe in psychiatrists and
that's okay because i'm not a
psychiatrist
uh so don't worry don't get so defensive
okay put your hands down
grant because you know what you've been
up to you know you've been acting very
strange your friends have been telling
me you've been acting different ever
since the pandemic
and grant let's just let's just talk
about it right it's time for an
intervention
[Music]
act like a boss not like a [ __ ] what's
next
is insane oh yeah
you're gonna see a whole new side
of uncle g
i'm talking crazy
are you ready can you handle it
will you love me or will you hate me
indeed grant now some of your friends
think it's just because you're losing a
lot of money during the pandemic now
on the rumors of my bankruptcy that is
soon to happen yes it's true
okay i'm losing the plane the condo we
all know you're stressed
grant and you know maybe it's time to
like meditate or something but
you got to stop posting to social media
buddy wait i don't need a lecture
i'm a grown goddamn grown man oh so he
finally
speaks huh well really you're so grown
explain this grant
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm yeah i know i'm speechless too grant
uh and that's not even all there is for
this next clip i'm actually gonna be uh
wearing some
safety protection this is for my safety
not for yours
grant when you see that video of
yourself do you see a man who is
sane have it to next day have it to next
day
nurse we're losing him come on come in
here nurse nurse get in here
we're losing them please we're losing
brains
patient record grant cardone i was
unable to get the patient responsive
for the rest of the session he would
only shout cryptically
have a 10x day but uh with a few more
sessions i do think that he may make
some progress
but notice that as soon as he left he
did post another tick tock
which is deeply concerning follow up
next week
it makes everything